welcome to this video or playing the
[ __ ]
Rasim escutia just I played him before
in a warm-up game which I lost with
various you could play which is not on
video yeah let's see what I can do here
it's playing some ancient the yenar game
bishops opening stuff and not bad so
it's fairly solid for white this kind of
opening you cannot expect much but it's
it's ok let's see what he's doing going
for a quickie Knight f-86 this early
Bishop g5 in some they normally don't
give much benefit
okay I'm ready for a night of it now
okay so what is this idea and we just
wants to take FIF and play something
like Queen d6 aw I don't know yeah I
don't know
when I get to g6 I will just get the
bishop here unless he plays something
like h3 now I don't know it looks very
unassuming for white anyway yeah well
that's obviously nothing let's see how
to do that yeah maybe maybe take and I
should see seven first off
not totally clearing down this more than
one one way to play that it just has to
retreat now then yeah I know this runs
right into a 95 but I came
in the game ahead before that this
warm-up game also didn't understand any
of his moves and lost anyway at the end
so let's let see
Jim he's gotten somewhat weird bishop
now on g3 check it's nothing
terrible yet but it's kind of a kind of
a weird piece let's see and I probably
wants to put the night to e3 I can do
that it's not doing much but I can do it
let's see yeah this night here to a5 is
a potential problem
I always have to protect if five years
that's not really that that noise I'd
like to trade his night off maybe I can
get it can get my night to the 6 and go
from there not easy not an easy endgame
you know that's it's it's an interesting
trade my night is not having many
squares this is this is a problem you
know of course should you go do it to c7
to d6 I can always put my bishop on
their forum and for getting it traded ok
this is this is a very weird way to play
it
from white no I'm just better here it's
not does not mean that I necessarily win
no but it's ok the way he's playing it
I'm getting close it was just just
terrible I have to play a 3 of course
and before okay
it's not an issue because my knight
cannot cannot move
95 maybe takes politics
that's probably the way to do it check
and takes king cakes and I'm going to
win the pawns should be a winning
endgame Jack
white resigns it's like that that
endgame quite in quite weird weird way I
mean um I really don't know why you
would play a for him I mean maybe it's
not a not a big issue and this is
unavoidable anyway because this is such
a dummy Bishop but I thought that after
that the only black can can can win of
course not sure that that I can actually
win but what really was bad I think is a
four I mean I really don't know how you
how you play it for here you have to
play a three obviously and go for this
put it on dark square so that I cannot
progress a4s is just bad not sure if you
if you can still hold it after that I
don't really think so yeah went with
this no no 95 just wins I don't release
no I mean if he moves the bishop some
way I get I get my knight into the game
I mean something like this is just
probably strategically lost yet in in
some in some long-winded way but it will
be will be losing at the end when this
night comes into play it simply asks
this bad pawn structure put this on
light squares as well
unnecessarily probably is this is I
don't know it's probably close to losing
the Congress just on 0.6 for black but
I'll show how deep a term comes in his
calculation that was some I know I mean
f4 I really wouldn't play but maybe
maybe it's not a big difference as some
his bishop is out of play on on g3
anyway which also
makes me question the move Knight f5
really I mean yeah I don't know it's
it's it's it's difficult difficult I
don't know maybe I can play 95 years
well that's not easy okay I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching